Hello everyone,
this is Isaac
Kurtzer, the Department
of Biomedical
Science, Old
Westbury campus.
And here will be the
first of two lectures
on the internal anatomy
of the brainstem.
Here we're going to
talk about the general
layout and major nuclei
of the brainstem.
Four session objectives
for this lecture.
The first is at the sky
high view of dividing
the brainstem into
its largest divisions,
medulla, pons, and
midbrain, as seen from
the external view and
transverse sections.
Then we're going to
focus on the major
structures, specifically
nuclei and tracts,
that can be seen from
the external anatomy.
There's visual evidence
of what that nuclei
and trachea is as
from the outside and
then the same from the
inside from a cross
-section are you able
to identify various
nuclei in a transverse
section of the
brainstem and cerebellum
and lastly when we
going over the placement
of cranial nerves
on the brainstem the
brainstem is a incredibly
complex set of
structures and that
is because there's so
many different types
of systems that are
packed into the same
general space of
midbrain pons and medulla
no doubt you've heard
of cranial nerve
nuclei and so they're
going to be getting
information from the
periphery about the face
and sending
information to control
different effectors of
the face they're there
we have major nuclei
like substantia *****
massive red nucleus
again big tectum these
are all massive nuclei
packed within the brain
stem reticular formation
is its own system
medial and lateral
reticulospinal tracts
and then different nuclei
they're involved in
things like micturation
and so on in brainstem
and then there's the
information going
up through the brainstem
on the way to thalamus
and from there to
cortex and then down
from cortex passing
through the brainstem to
drive lower motor neurons
in the spinal cord
so all that together
creates a lot of
complexity in terms of
function and geometrically
what does it look
like to have all these
structures sharing the
same neighborhood and
they're pushing and
jostling against each other
so here we have a
sagittal section of the
brain right down the
midline that's keeping
the cerebellum and
cerebrum intact so we're
able to see the brainstem
in relationship to
these other large
structures and your job is
going to first identify
what is the medulla
pons and midbrain and
there they should be
clear as as I that you
have the medulla which
is the most caudal
portion that really
resembles from the outside
very similar to the
spinal cord and then
when we get to the pons
it really has changed
from an external view
quite a bit because
we have this bulbous
shape to the ventral
portion of it and then
we're at the midbrain
which is the most
rostral portion of the
brainstem and it is
going to be a very stock
with a much greater
diameter than we have
with the medulla and
then we're going to
have other obvious
features about it that
distinguish it from the
medulla and pons
underneath now during the
as you're moving
throughout this neural
axis there's going
to be a great deal of
changes that are happening
underneath but you
can get a general idea
about where you are
by looking in relationship
to surrounding
structures and there'll
be features that are
only seen um at a
certain level like i'm
drawing right within
this or highlighting
right within this
the fourth ventricle
and so if you see a
a chamber in cross
-section that's there's
obviously it's a space
then you should be
oh well that's the
fourth ventricle I I
must be really at the
pons or I'm above
doing a cross-section
through here through
the midbrain well one
indication of that
would be the cerebral
aqueduct, which is only
present in the midbrain
as the CSF flows from
third ventricle into
fourth ventricle. So
again, it's going to be
very useful for you
to have a general
orientation of what does
the structure look like
and then hone in on
the particulars rather
than try and memorize
a bunch of of pictures
per se that are
disconnected from each other
three external views
of the brainstem after
removing the cerebellum
and also after removing
all of the brain
above the migraine so
it looks kind of a bit
strange here it's not
one you'd see normally
it's a kind of brainstem
in isolation so
ventral dorsal lateral
and each of them is
going to have a midbrain
pons and medulla and
what you are expected
to understand for the
next few slides is how
you can do some bumpology
and string ology
that is go from the
bumps that we see on the
external surface to
infer what are the
structures that created
that bump of course you
could name the bump
that's all well and good
but you're like what
does that signify the
bump does it mean
something yes it does it
means a collection of
cell bodies so when you
see a bump that is going
to reflect a nucleus
that is underneath
likewise you see strings
and you see ropes well
those are going to
reflect tracks okay
and we can name those
tracks and then they
might disappear because
they're coursing
underneath some other
structures and think of
this creature that we have
on the right a mole
it caused you some
hassle because it's
digging for uh i don't know
all the little grubs
and slugs that are in
your garden and as it's
burrowing underneath
the surface you know
that there was a mole
that moved along that
course that there's a
tunnel underneath and
so that is um has some
equivalence to what
your job is for the next
several slides look
on the outside and try
and for what's on the
inside because it will
become very unintuitive
just looking at a
slice okay those are
that's very tough so
you can name this here
but if you don't think
about what's this that
that bump is related
to you're going to have
a serious disconnect
moving forward we
have a ventral view of
the brain stem with the
cerebellum and cerebral
cortex removed as
long as well as the
spinal cord so starting
at the top we have the
cerebral peduncles
which are these massive
stock of fibers they're
originating in cerebral
cortex and passing on
through the internal
capsule and then we
see them continue at
this point entering into
the ponds and they're
basically from our
perspective disappear
but then re-emerge a
fraction of them as the
pyramids so it's thicker
at the top than the
bottom because there
are fibers of the
cerebral peduncle that
are terminating within in
the basilar ponds now
the fibers that continue
through are the
corticospinal tract so
the pyramids are
corticospinal tract fibers
it's called the pyramids
because we have a
broader extent at the
top than at the bottom
maybe a little bit
subtle okay so the more
narrow at the bottom than
the top because those
are fibers that are
recoalescing together
as they are diving on
through the basilar
ponds they separate
out and they have to
recoalesce so now we have
these columns recollected
again and then it's
obliterated at the
bottom no more pyramid
here no more columns
it's just flat across
here because that is
where you have the
decussation from left to
right of these fibers
now on the we'll say the
upper third of the
pyramids and immediately
lateral is a structure
called the olive this
swelling that looks
like you guessed it an
olive when you see the
nucleus that's underneath
that creates the
swelling in cross
-section now you're pointing
at the nucleus itself
it's called the
inferior olivary nucleus
but from the outside
it's called the olive
so this comes up a number
of times that there's
a naming convention
for something that is
seen on the outside
that is the external
manifestation of some
structure that's underneath
and you know just
to understand that
there's a relationship
but you shouldn't fully
confuse the two now the
last point I want to
mention here is at the
Basler ponds you can
see what look like
these lines of tension
running left right and
as you might have guessed
that is because
there's fibers that are
going left to right
and those will in fact
continue laterally
and become the middle
cerebellar peduncle which
we'll cover later on.
And it's because
these fibers from the
cerebral cortex are
moving on through this
crisscross of information
that is that is
what's creating this
swelled big belly
of the basilar pons
because basically a bit
of a it's kind of
inefficient you know
you have one road
system that's going down
and another road system
that's going left
and right and it's
kind of like a traffic
jam of information
and the result of
that is it gets swelled
out in interiorly
here we have a dorsal
view of the brain
stem at the most
rostral portion which is
the midbrain you can see
the superior colliculus
and inferior
colliculus these large
nuclei together are
termed the tectum so
the midbrain has the
tectum on the dorsal
side moving on down we
have structures that
connect the
brain stem to the
cerebellum right
remember no wi
-fi and there
are on each side
three peduncles so these
peduncles are fiber
tracks they're like
i said connecting the
brain stem and the
cerebellum so superior
cerebellar peduncle
middle cerebellar peduncle
inferior cerebellar
peduncle. Why? Because
the superior peduncle
is the most superior.
The inferior peduncle
is the most inferior,
and the middle is the
one between the two.
I would call this
the lateral but it's
the largest of the bunch
now fourth ventricle
would be right here
situated between the
back of the pons and
cerebellum which I've
removed so this is the
floor of the fourth
ventricle now at this
level them crossing
between is the
medulla. The medulla is
going to be ending at
this point, the lowest
point of the fourth
ventricle, the obex.
And below that,
we see these two
structures, G and
C, for the gracile
and cuniate tubercles.
Okay, we've got
some asterisks to
the side to really
bring it out a
little bit better.
Inside the tubercle
is the nucleus. So
the tubercle is what
you see on the outside.
The nucleus is what
is found on the
inside, and both of
these are going to be
part of the medulla.
They're on the dorsal
side, and they're
associated with the
fiber tracts that
are traveling up the
spinal cord as far as
the dorsal finunculi.
So these are also called
dorsal column nuclei.
A view from the
lateral vantage.
At the uppermost portion,
we again have the
superior and inferior
colliculi. so remember
those are on the
dorsal side so we're
looking have not purely
lateral but dorsolaterally
so we can see it
extending to the back
below that which is now
the pons because these
two collicula are
part of the midbrain
below that for the pons
we see that distended
interior portion for
the basilar pons and we
can see on the um
back side here cutting
through the middle
cerebellar peduncle i want
you to notice how
these fibers or looks
like fibers would be
moving right here that
little mole underneath
the um the surface of
your garden garden
burrowing from this point
to that point is
creating this middle
cerebellar peduncle okay
those fibers are creating
this middle cerebellar
peduncle we'll be
covering that more in
the cerebellum lecture
but just try to see
that why we have the
this distended shape
is because as we have
these fibers traveling
back here to coalescing
into this very large
fiber tract that is
communicating with the
cerebellum the sections
that you're going to
be seeing in subsequent
slides are all stained
and so that means
you need to think about
what is being stained
what is the dye
adhering to we will be
showing you myelin
stained slides so that is
the dye is going to adhere
to the phospholipids
which are found in
myelin and myelin is
going to be surrounding
the tracks or go
when you see dark
regions that means that
you'll have a whole
lot of tracks traveling
through that portion of
the brainstem so when
we have a section
here upper midbrain or
actually i'd say that's
mid midbrain we have
looking over here this
dark uh le stained
tissue well that must be
tracks and this lightly
stained tissue over
here well that must be
nuclei okay so in
this for myelin stain
tracks the things that
are light aren't nothing
they are something
and they are nuclei
because those are not
where you're going to be
having myelin present
so get that right now
I see what is light
what is dark and in
theory we could flip
it around and have a
nuclear stained images
but we don't going forward
when you see those
dark bundles in the
front that's oh that's
because it's myelin
-stained major way of
delineating regions of the
brainstem is anterior
to posterior so we
have the tectum which
is found in the midbrain
and only the midbrain
that's on the right
with the blue that'll
be the superior inferior
colliculi together
and interior Prior
to that is the entire
region, the tegmentum,
which is going
to be including
reticular formation,
some cerebral
aqueducts, some
assorted nerves.
So we can go from
midbrain, pons, and
medulla and see this
complexity of the tissue
within that. And so
all of the territory
that is posterior to
the inferior olive of
the medulla, that's
all going to be
tegmentum, okay? And all
of the territory that
is interior to that
crisscrossy pattern
that we see in the
ponds is the tegmentum.
Now,
again, back with the
ponds, that crisscrossy
material that we
see back and forth,
and then there's those
dark areas that are
within it that is all
basilar ponds okay
so it's all of a different
sort of structure
and again with the
medulla the pyramids
that's part of
basilar ponds and for
the cerebral peduncles
so this is where
you're going to be having
those large descending
tracks among some
other structures.
I'm going to try to
further bridge what we
see from the outside
to what we see on the
inside of the
brainstemmer in terms of
this general orientation,
okay, that you know
that you're in the
medulla. How? Well,
it's a tubular
structure, right? Overall
tubular structure. and
that's what we see when
we're looking on the
outside and we do a
transverse section
through it lo and behold
it remains a tubular
structure in that
vantage okay so tubular
structure rostral
tubular structure
caudal it's going to
be changing shape along
the way it's going
to correspond to those
things that we saw
on the outside and
one of the things is
going to be at them
as you reach to the
top we're getting to
the end of the fourth
ventricle so see this
section right here
okay so the fourth
ventricle is ending
and that is why we're
seeing it over here
and by this point the
caudal is completely
ended okay so it is
overall tubular but
has these changes
in shape that should
correspond to what you
see from the outside
and i want you to
start thinking about
what would be some
of those other things
that we identified like
the gracile and cuneate
nuclei which are on
the dorsal side because
they're called dorsal
column nuclei where
would they be within
this image and i
should bring out that
these images that we see
in cross-section always
have dorsal on top
okay this is dorsal
this would be ventral
okay this is ventral
this is dorsal this is
hard and fast for any
slices that you look
at with regards to
brainstem in this
presentation or others
that ventral is going to
be on bottom has two
cross sections through
the ponds one at a
more caudal portion
another at a more rostral
portion and we can
see in both cases that
the ventral side is
very bowed out right so
we can see this belly
going out like that
and so here we can see
the curving towards
the bottom which is the
ventral side and what
is back um behind it
is going to be the
uh or on top here is
the dorsal side so dorsal
would be on the top
of this image and what
would be posterior
to the brain stem but
the cerebellum so this
tissue that you see
back here is actually
cerebellum This back
here is cerebellum. And
between the brainstem
and the cerebellum is
the fourth ventricle.
So this space that we
have that I'm drawing
out on the left side,
that space corresponds
to these openings,
that is open space of
the fourth ventricle.
Lastly, and
most rostrally,
we have the midbrain.
The midbrain, when seen
from these transverse
sections at the
rostral and caudal
extent, are going to
have some things that are
characteristic
throughout that extent.
First off, we have these
large, large column
-like structures, just
absolutely massive.
We'll see those from
that interior view or
the ventral view when
we're looking at the
external anatomy. and
we can see how dark the
material is in there
signifying that these
are going to be containing
axons myelinated
axons that's why it's
dark we can see on
the back these bumps
here's some bumps here
and here are some bumps
there those bumps are
the inferior and
superior colliculi which
are very evident when
you're looking at the
dorsal surface lastly
we can see this pore
in the center let me
move it away see that
poor pointing to here
it is over that poor
you have a little fly
circling around it that
poor is the cerebral
aqueduct which is
positioned behind the
superior colliculus and
in before the tegmentum
okay so that is going
to be in behind the
tectum and in front
of the tegmentum here
it's this pore on the
side and And within
the tegmentum, there's
going to be many different
tracks, but we can
see the general
structure in this image,
and we'll get to the
details moving forward.
Now we're at the point
where we have many
different sections
shown on the left.
We have eight different
sections. on the
right we have the
levels at which those
sections were made
and we're going to
go one by one by one
and say what do we
find here what do we
find here and we're
gonna find what
nuclei will also be
tracks there of course
but this This section
is about nuclei,
this first lecture.
Here are the nuclei
that we'll need to
identify and understand
their function broadly.
This broad
identification function,
you'll have lectures
that are dedicated
to certain topics
like the cerebellum
and we'll be talking
about red nucleus,
dentate nucleus in
more detail all right
but you need to know
these functions at some
general level so I
say red nucleus to be
like oh yeah that's
in the midbrain I know
what that looks like
and I know that's
motor related you
should also be aware
what's the side of the
body that the nucleus
is going to be
related to processing
information so the red
nucleus would be for motor
related information
of the contralateral
side of the body
and so we have five
different nuclei to
identify in the midbrain
two in the pons really
one in the pons and
at the two of the
pons level because the
dentic nucleus is not in
the pons it's actually
a cerebellar nucleus
which is evident at
the section at the
level of the pons a
transverse section and
the medulla we have the
two dorsal column nuclei
the inferior olivary
nucleus that will
correspond to the olive
that we see on the
outside the criceal and
cuneate corresponding
to the tubercles that
we see on the outside
and finally the spinal
trigeminal nucleus
and what will we be
looking for we'll be
looking for light areas
because those are going
to be unstained by a
myelin stain meaning
that they are nuclei
and that's will include
cranial nerve nuclei
as well that's for
another day here we're
focusing on quote unquote
these major nuclei
we are now looking at
the most caudal of the
eight sections of the
brainstem and so I've
drawn a small little
green box around the
column of slices and
that corresponds to
the larger image it's
the very same it's
duplicated but that on
the right it helps keep
you in mind how we're
moving on up and should
be you know mentioned
that these are not
scaled according to
size specifically it's
kind of a ******* size
that you see that the
medulla is I don't know
I'm just gonna call
this a thumb width
across and then I'm here
at the pons you're
like okay maybe that's
like three thumb widths
across but that's
not the case in reality
reality it'd be like
10 thumb whips across
or something along
those lines so it's it's
not perfectly scaled
in dimensions as we're
going on up the pons
is much larger it's just
a kind of a cautionary
note now going back
up to the top we
need to find um nuclei
and this remember that
the gracile tubercle
was um the most caudal
of of the of the two
okay and so it appears
at the most caudal
level here it's white
and um fg and fc this
is going to be uh
pointing to the tracks
that are related to us
but these are not
nuclei this is a facile
gracilis the uh uh
fasciculus and uh fasciculus
kuniatus okay so these
are tracks and these
white ones are nuclei
now this large structure
right here that is
the spinal trigeminal
nucleus this is a
nucleus that is important
for processing of pain
and temperature of
the face and it actually
extends further into
the spinal cord and
it extends further on
up within the medulla
so it's really quite
massive and but they
decided to call it spinal
because at least a
portion of it was there
Now we're at the next
higher level, we can
see because the green
box is at the level
above corresponding to
this image. We can also
see that the line
popped up a level as it
is making a transverse
section through the
brainstem through the
medulla. still we can
see ah these bumps it's
passed through another
bump that we see on
the outside according
to my science of
bumpology those tubercles
correspond to nuclei
meaning now i see the
cuneate um and the
gracile nucleus together
if you only saw the
gracile that means that
you are lower than
this and you could be
at a point where you
only see the cuneate as
well it might be
the case in one
textbook or another
the so when we show
you and test you
it's not necessarily
going to be these
exact images right
we're not trying to
get you to remember
this image but rather
this this structure
right not this one
dog but i don't know a
particular breed of
dogs okay and so i
encourage you to look
through the you're going
to have to see this
with the lab they'll
have some different
images there and that
will help you see it
wasn't cut at exactly
the same place each
time okay now here's
the obex you remember
that is the lowest um
portion of the fourth
ventricle i think i
misspoke earlier i
said the lowest portion
of the pedula that's
not that's not true
it's the lowest portion
of the fourth ventricle
okay so caudal to
this it will be um no
more fourth ventricle
they'll be narrowing
down into the central
canal of the spinal
cord we still have
our spinal trigeminal
nucleus to the side and
we have a whole bunch
of other activity
going on which we'll be
talking about um later
we're just focusing
really on the the
nuclei that you have in
front of you one level
up in our sectioning
along the brain stem
now this back portion
has opened up into the
fourth ventricle so
the section is through
here so it's this
level where you can see
clear fourth ventricle
and we have a
sectioning through this
complex structure which
is the inferior olivary
nucleus from the
outside called the olive
and there's a very
distinct shape which
has been likened to a
crumpled purse but you
know that depends on
the fashion of the day
and the type of purse
that you have you'll
see that description
a crumpled purse it
certainly looks like
a crumpled something
and um very very
distinct and you're going
to be seeing this um at
many different sections
of the medulla
because it has a quite
large um structure um
so medulla will continue
I could cut even
more rostrally and
you'll still be within
medulla, but this is the
last within this
section that I'm talking
about. We're glad the
next slide is going
to be moving into
talking about the ponds.
And here we are the first
section through
the ponds.
Grab that little
pointer we can see this
green line cutting on
through the external
views of the brainstem
and so that would
correspond to this image
we see on the right and
it's blown up in the
center top we see the
characteristic features
of the ponds that
we talked about before
that is the bulbous
characteristic of
basilar pons the fourth
ventricle and behind that
the cerebellum now we
see this large crumpled
purse like structure
that is not the
inferior of repeat this
is not the inferior of
it looks very similar
because they are
genetically related but
this is a nucleus that
is placed within the
cerebellum and is in
fact a cerebellar nucleus
the other nucleus is
placed on the interior
surface of the medulla
later on you'll
learn that it communicates
with the cerebellum
and so that's why
you have these shared
features as something
was duplicated and
moved around suffice to
say here do not confuse
the two at the pons at
the posterior portion
behind the fourth
ventricle that is the
dentate okay it's very
visible dentate nucleus
it looks like teeth
that's what's dead
take dead dead teen
dandelion okay so we have
the pontine nuclei
within the ponds and
you're like where and
that's because there's
many of them thousands
and thousands and
thousands of teeny
tiny pontine nuclei and
each one of those
tiny nuclei will be
sending out fibers to
the contralateral side
so the nuclei over
on the right will be
sending them to the
left and the nuclei on
the left we sending
them to the right and
that causes a gigantic
traffic jam because
you have fibers that
are coming through
it they're vertically
oriented and all All
of that is going to
create this bowed out
or bulbous structure
of the ponds because
you have this highway
that's crossing
one way, crossing the
other way, crossing
on through it. It
creates a bit of a mess,
bulges out the ponds.
I should mention
that the fibers
over here are coming
from the nuclei.
So it's the fibers
that are creating
this sense of motion.
But I'm pointing
to the white stuff,
which is the cell
bodies of the fibers,
pontine nuclei.
Next slide.
Now we're at
a higher level
sectioning
through the ponds.
How do you know
it's the ponds?
Well, look at what we
got here. we got the
bulbous basilar pons
that we see on the
interior aspect we have
again the fourth ventricle
and behind that we
have the cerebellum
this looks like a pons
you should be somewhat
comfortable about
that at this point
maybe not enough to
test but it should seem
familiar oh I see a
fourth ventricle I see
some material behind
it I see this bulbous
structure I know that
I'm in the pons well is
there anything remarkable
uh besides that
well the pontine nuclei
we can see all of
this white in the front
and so that's going
to be each one of them
is sending off axons
contralaterally this
is the last of the
sections through
the pons we have
three of them we're
at the most rostral
extent where that
fourth ventricle is
narrowing down to
the cerebral aqueduct
Okay, there's
going to be a
point where
it's a bit of a
transition zone.
But once you're in
the midbrain
That will be cerebral
Aqueduct. Okay,
so this is the
narrowing of
that lake to the
river. It's
all one body of
Water of CSF. Okay,
and so the very
very top here.
So I want to also
point out here We
really can see that
I want to highlight
behind here this is
the tegmentum we were
talking about before
so ahead is the
basilar portion behind
would be the tegmentum
in the midbrain not
only do we have the
basilar portion and
the tegmentum we also
have tectum which is
composed of the
inferior and superior
colliculus we're at a low
level or caudal portion
of the midbrain I can
tell because I can
see this black material
in the front this
is going to be axons
because it's a staining
again for myelin and
so that means that
there's some axons
here and they're
actually crossing things
are going from the left
to the right things
from going from the
right to the left and
so on so that is a
decussation of a
peduncle and we'll be
covering those peduncles
later on the decussation
of the superior
peduncle so if you see
this decussation
very clear then
you know that this
is the inferior
colliculus
cerebral aqueduct
that will be above
the fourth ventricle
it narrowed down into
the river which is
the cerebral aqueduct
and then there is pale
uh tissue surrounding
it so that would
be periaqueductal gray
that's gray matter
around the cerebral
aqueduct and that's
there's nuclear there's
a cell bodies that
are there now we're
at a higher level of
the um midbrain we
can see still the
cerebral aqueduct, which
continues throughout
the midbrain. Okay,
that's eventually
going to feed into the
third ventricle. And
around that is the
periaqueductal gray.
This colliculi, this
is going to be tectum.
And so interior to
that is the tegmentum.
and here this dark is
going to be the basilar
portion of the midbrain
posterior to that
is this large nucleus
the substantia *****
it really is um quite
large and shouldn't
be mistaken for
anything else. This dark
region right here is
again staining because
of tracts which we
cover extensively in the
next lecture but let
me just mention for
reference this is again
the superior peduncle
a superior cerebellar
above peduncle
efference that it's
actually outputs it's from
the cerebellum okay and
so at this level it's
still a little bit
tough to say whether
what is behind what
are this colliculus
whether it's the inferior
or superior i would
probably bet that
this is a superior um
colliculus but it becomes
um unambiguous if we
are at a higher level
than this we are more
rostral then it will
become unambiguous and
I'll show you why
soon now we are at the
highest or most rostral
section through the
brainstem which means
through the midbrain
and we see a additional
nucleus come on the
scene the red nucleus
you can see that it
is behind the substantia
***** and this is
a massive nucleus you
will be able to see
this by eye when you
look through a section
of tissue in the anatomy
lab it It clearly
stands out. And this
red nucleus, which is
in the rostral midbrain,
at that point, the
big old bump of the
tectum that you see at
the dorsal portion
of the midbrain, this
is undoubtedly superior
colliculus. so if
you see red nucleus and
you have a transverse
section which is the
only ones that we do
then the um the colliculus
that is going to
be at that level is
the superior colliculus
um when you see
the decussation of
the superior cerebellar
peduncle like
we had in two images
is before it's
going to be the
inferior and then
between it's a little
bit hard to say
go through here and
see if you can name the
nuclei right we we did
all that stuff you're
paying attention i'm
sure what what did
you learn how about if
you test yourself what
do you think a is b c
d and e hit pause here
because i'm about to
give you the answers
there you go on the
right that's the answers
to a substantia *****
b inferior olive c
pontine nuclei d spinal
trigeminal nucleus e
inferior colliculus I
hope that you got all
those right if not
I'm just gonna have to
practice a little bit
more you'll get it now
we've entered into the
last portion of the
presentation where we're
going to focus on the
cranial nerves and how
they are arranged on
the surface of the
brain stem there is a
ventral view presented
on the left dorsal view
of the brain stem
presented on the right you
can see right off that
the very different
size of the two boxes.
So what's on the right
delineates or outlines
the solitary nerve
associated with the
dorsal aspect of the
brainstem, as the
trochlear nerve is the
only one that is
attached on the dorsal
side. All of the others
are attached to the
ventral side or not
not at all so I'm not
showing you cranial
nerve one and two which
are not attached to the
brain stem but three
through twelve are
with the exception of
number four now the
arrangement of these nerves
can be understood
not just by a visual
glance but according to
a rule. I'd like to move
to that rule on the
next slide because I
believe it will help
you out understand what
is otherwise some
pretty complex geometry.
Okay so we're going to
go through a rule and
it's kind of a little
bit like a dance.
You step to the left,
you step to the right,
you do the hokey-pokey,
you turn yourself
around. We're going
to have something like
that. We're going to
move in some sequence
in and out and that
will correspond to the
numbers and the rules
go that you start off
going rostral caudally
to count down the
numbers you know 3
through 12 start rostral
caudally 3 4 5 6 and
then the next rule is
moving medial laterally
seven eight then we
have moving rostral
caudally again nine ten
eleven and finally we
do a jump to the side
and up again to twelve
so let me get out my
pen or actually my well
here's a pen drawing
down across down
and then up so these
three six seven and eight
are at the pontomedullary
junction the nine
ten eleven are on
the lateral aspect of
the medulla and then
12 is jumping over the
olive so this is going
to be on the medial
side of the olive so
practice yourself this
little dance going
rastral caudal medial
lateral rastral caudal
up and back medial roster
you can make whatever
particular phrasing
of that play it to
whatever music you'd
like but that is the
general rule of how
they're laid out and now
let's go back to the
tissue now we're back at
the last informational
slide where we have
the cranial nerves
nine through excuse me
three through twelve so
that'll be from ocular
motor to hypoglossal
and you can take your
time going through
looking at what these
nerves look like and
you can look through the
lab manual for more
examples do that on your
own time for right now
I want to remind you
of some very important
facts that somehow get
dropped or misplaced
is more more likely.
Nerves are part
of the PNS.
Tracts are part
of the CNS.
So when you say
tract, that means that
you're talking about
something within the
parenchyma of the
nervous system, within a
central nervous system.
we say nerve that
means that you're
part of the peripheral
nervous system now
all cranial nerves
innervate ipsilateral
tissue okay it might
be afferents efferents
both what not it's
complex that's why
you have to spend time
learning it but it's
always the left nerve
always innervates
tissue on the left
period the right nerve
innervates tissue on
the right period
ipsilateral that's not a
hard rule when it
comes to tracks there
they can be mixed and
that is where um um
things get confusing
because you can have
a mixed nerve that's
ipsilateral and
then you can have
tracks that may not be
mixed but they could
be contralateral
and then they're
associated with cranial
nerve nuclei and how
does that all work
out we'll save that
for another lecture
all right that
is the end of the
new material
now let's give a
few summary points
the brainstem
has three major divisions
medulla pons and
midbrain and they look
very different from
each other whether
you're looking from the
front you're looking
from the side you're
looking from the back
from the external view
they look quite
different when you do a
transverse cross-section
you can see different
regions divided into
anterior and posterior
the tectum is one
that is only found in
dorsal membrane the
tegmentum is interior
to that it's going to
be found at all levels
as is the basilar
division and that's going
to be at all levels
there will be distinct
nuclei at each level
of the brainstem and
there's a rational
ordering a way of ordering
the cranial nerves
with that little dance
we went over all
right I hope that that
material was clear
enough and that if it
wasn't if there were
some major gaps or if I
did some goofs to or
what not. Let me know.
It's a work in
progress and
feedback is appreciated.
Thank you very much.